et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec sébastien boussois docteur en
sciences politiques chercheurs et
spécialistes des questions de terrorisme
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
alors c'est une réalité l'activité
terroriste a été réduite dans les pays
occidentaux pendant le confinement duo
kobe 19 comment est-ce qu'on peut
l'expliquer écoutez je dirais que c'est
de l'ordre de l'évidence à partir du
moment où vous n'avez personne dans
l'espace public
à partir du moment où vous n'avez aucune
cible évidemment il y a peu de risque
d'y avoir un attentat c'est en cela que
je suis assez sceptique sur ce type de
rapport puisque on le voit bien tous a
rebasculé largement à travers les écrans
et à travers internet pour le coup comme
l'a dit très justement ce sera porteur
des chats bien rebondi sur l'idée même
de l'aco vide en exploitant son
idéologie préféré c'est à dire en
considérant que l'aco vider son
expansion l'expansion de cette pandémie
était en réalité un châtiment un
châtiment divin mais ce qui est beaucoup
plus inquiétant bien évidemment c'est
que même s'il n'y a pas eu visiblement
d'attentats dans nos pays dits en paix
ça ne doit pas pour autant valider un
argument qui serait de dire que le tout
sécuritaire serait l'argument idéal pour
qu'il n'y est évidemment pas de
terrorisme je rappelle quand même que le
4 avril dernier
il y a eu un attentat à romans-sur-isère
que cet homme est sorti de chez lui et a
été se balader donné des coups de
couteau aux abords d'un café il
semblerait quand même que le confinement
et eu raison pour le coup de sa de sa
raison donc il ya aussi des conséquences
à long terme à mon avis extrêmement
importante sur la perte de d'emprise sur
le terrain notamment en termes de
prévention sur le contrôle très
difficile d'internet sur ce qu'a dit
très justement le rapporteur le
relâchement des suivis de tous ces
individus qui sont en prison et pour
lequel une partie sera libéré avant 2022
donc il ya un fossé lien
id je dirais spatio temporelle de trois
quatre mois qui risque fort d'avoir des
conséquences par la suite est ce qu'on
doit à t'inquiéter des cellules
terroristes déjà implanté dans notre
pays est ce qu elles sont nombreuses
est ce qu'elles sont suffisamment
surveillé par les autorités
je crois que les autorités les services
font le maximum de ce qu'il est possible
de faire mais par définition ces
cellules dormantes ou ces cellules en
veille savent très bien se savent très
bien se cacher il ya aujourd'hui dans le
monde une quarantaine de franchise de
l'état islamique qui se reconvertit rond
dans autre chose si demain il y as je
dirais une nouvelle marque plus plus
rentables et ça ne l'a pas empêché
effectivement les attentats au niger ou
aux philippines encore récemment
je crois que la france reste de toute
façon la cible numéro 1 de ce type de
franchise de l'état islamique à cause de
la laïcité comme d'habitude à cause
également du plus grand nombre de
musulmans qu'il y a en europe et qui du
coup paraît rentable je dirais pour des
ch en termes de recrutement autant ciel
malheureusement de jeunes qui à un
moment ou un autre seront séduits par
cette idéologie parce que le contexte de
la crise économique et social à venir
est extrêmement grave que beaucoup de
jeunes seront soit en décrochage
scolaire soit n'auront pas d'emploi et
pourront un moment ou un autre est la
cible idéale des recruteurs alors avec
cette crise sanitaire du côté d'edf qui
perdure un peu partout dans le monde est
ce qu'on peut voir apparaître de
nouvelles formes de terrorisme
oui alors apparaître en tant que tels
que ce soit les autorités belges ou
françaises par exemple la menace numéro
un reste le reste le jihad la deuxième
reste les droites et les extrêmes
droites et les ultra droite plus
précisément et on voit aussi évidemment
une montée à dans le terreau le contexte
du confinement d ultra gauche avec par
exemple les attaques contre les antennes
5 g mais pas seulement vous le voyez aux
etats-unis en espagne vous le voyez en
allemagne vous avez un regroupement des
extrêmes qui protestent contre
l'autorité contre l'incompétence de
certains gouvernements à prévenir et à
protéger leurs propres populations
vous avez des mouvements qui s'organise
aux états unis pratiquement deux
formations paramilitaires ou deux de
guérilla urbaine qui vont s'en prendre
aux uns et aux
il y à des risques extrêmement présent
de micro guerre civile
ce qui était le projet rêvé de dèche au
sein de nos sociétés et vous le voyez
bien si on se retrouve demain dans une
nouvelle situation de confinement
cumuler avec une crise économique et
sociale dont on ne saura pas comment
s'en sortir licenciement faillite et
autres je crois qu'on va évidemment vers
de graves dangers et une multiplication
des frondes menace sébastien boussois
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes docteur en
sciences politiques est chercheur et
spécialiste des questions de terrorisme
merci beaucoup